[Music]
today is the anniversary of the
Gettysburg Address and it's also Larry
King's birthday that's right two great
events that happened 150 years ago
actually at Larry's older he reported at
that event right didn't talk as long as
we thought but what are you gonna do and
why the fourscore who the hell knows
that mean what else is going on
President Obama is being criticized for
not attending today's ceremony
commemorating the Gettysburg Address
yeah in fairness though Lincoln did not
attend Obama's sorry about this crappy
website speech that's not up there with
one of his great speech the sorry about
his crappy website address Obamacare of
sorry Obama wrestling with the health
care rollout debacle yesterday President
Obama urged Americans not to be put off
by the Obamacare website and he offered
alternative ways to enroll such as using
the mail then the president got back on
his horse and rode off to spread the
news to the next
he's the man hitting his horse a lot man
whoops you know according to a new poll
that just came out if the election were
held today Mitt Romney would beat Barack
Obama yeah a spokesman for a spokesman
for Mitt Romney said no he'd find a way
to blow it didn't you have a horse -
Mitt Romney yeah yeah
just picturing Mitt Romney riding by on
his dancing horse sorry folks
Rob Ford the crack smoking mayor of
Toronto
[Applause]
that's all you have to do with that guy
right is just mention him right
hey everybody crack smoking mayor of
Toronto still getting he's actually
still getting a lot of free press the
Toronto City Council this is the latest
has voted to strip Mayor Rob Ford of
most his duties making him just a
figurehead that's what happened yeah now
maybe it's just me but isn't the last
thing we want to do is give this guy
more free time you don't have to do
anything your time is your own in an
interview Mayor Rob Ford said he doesn't
have a drug problem he has a weight
problem yeah by that he means he can't
wait to do drugs
[Music]
probably heard about this too of former
Vice President Dick Cheney's daughters
are fighting publicly over the issue of
same-sex marriage
yeah well Dick Cheney today he said it
pains him that his daughters are feuding
yeah he said it's the first time I've
ever felt conflicted about a war I'm
more interested by the response than the
joke itself a pause a gasp yeah some
ooze then some laughter then ending in
applause yeah we just scanned the whole
range of human emotions
[Applause]
[Music]
this strange the oxford dictionary has
named selfie to be the word of the year
narrowly beating out twerk yeah in a
related story the funeral for the
english language is this saturday pretty
good really excellent yeah thanks I get
it you're burying a language that out
what why aren't you ever here to help me
know is there like try again you carrot
top clown